emmanuel macron à roubaix pour la
clôture du beauvau de la sécurité une
réunion débuter cette année entre le
gouvernement castex mais aussi des
syndicats de police plusieurs mois de
concertation pour améliorer leurs
conditions d'exercice mais aussi
consolider le lien avec les français des
annonces pour cette clôture du beauvau
de la sécurité qui a donc que commencer
il ya sept mois et qui a été lancé après
le tabassage par des policiers du
producteur de musique michel est clair
fin 2020 emmanuel macron avait alors
reconnu l'existence de contrôle au
faciès et des violences policières le
président qui a donc notamment à nous
c'est tout à leur 500 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour renforcer les
moyens des forces de l'ordre
en 2022 le ministère de l'intérieur
verra ainsi son budget augmenter de près
de 1,5 milliard d'euros dont 500
millions d'euros pour la mise en oeuvre
des premières mesures du beauvau de la
sécurité
c'est sans précédent
95 %
95 % de ces mesures qui ressorte du
beauvau sont pour du matériel de
l'investissement les conditions de
travail et du côté de la police ou des
porcs à un manque de moyens on attentes
de réformes beaucoup coûté tout porte
parole l'île de france paris unité sgp
police fo espère une vraie réponse du
gouvernement
le président pour l'instant ce qu'il
nous dit il faut peut-être plus contrôlé
à paulista sera alors que la police je
vous lis l'institution la plus contrôlée
dans ce pays donc j'espère que ces
annonces vont pas se limiter à cela oui
des effectifs puis de la formation quid
des matériels savez il faut une voix
réformes dans la police nationale digne
de ce nom dans ce pays depuis plus de 20
ans nus des réformes est un ministre qui
se déplace dans tel à tel ou tel endroit
qui nous dit voilà il y aura dix
policiers depuis sa fréjus cinq
policiers de plus cinq ans non nous ce
qu'on veut c'est un véritable plan
marshall pour la police avec des moyens
l'appui puisque on a une institution qui
tombe en décrépitude
des commissariats vétus des manques
d'effectifs partout donc si on veut
assurer nos missions correctement et
bien faire notre travail encore faut-il
qu'on lui même façon dans de bonnes
conditions c'est ça qu'on demande ni
plus ni moins